[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue c'est un vrai plaisir
de vous retrouver paris saclay tv vous
fait vivre
étape après étape la métamorphose de
votre territoire
parmi les nouveaux quartiers celui des
savoirs à guyancourt quartier qui va
bientôt voir arriver la ligne 18 du
grand paris express avec beaucoup de
changements à la clé des balades
urbaines vous permettre d'arpenter de
découvrir ces nouveaux lieux visite
guidée dans un instant un environnement
créé pour vous et avec vous grâce
notamment à l'urbanisme transitoire
connaissez-vous les activateurs de
territoire eh bien il s'agit tout
simplement de penser de manière
différente la ville et nous allons vous
faire rencontrer une activatrice elle
s'appelle joséphine combat les designers
elle travaille pour l'agencé vraiment
fremm le design justement il a désormais
son laboratoire ou quand les sciences
rencontre les arts
rien n'échappe à la recherche
scientifique une exposition à découvrir
à l'école normale supérieure de paris
saclay et c'est un site insolite des
vestiges d'une villa gallo romaine qui
est situé au coeur du campus urbain des
vestiges qui nous raconte une histoire
celle de votre territoire et enfin vous
vous posez peut-être cette question mais
que faire cet été un été des confiné on
s'en réjouit et bien vous allez le voir
beaucoup d'événements prévus c'est dans
notre agenda
et c'est à la fin de cette émission
je vous emmène découvrir un futur
nouveau quartier de guyancourt celui des
savoirs des balades urbaines ont été
organisées pour découvrir le site
l'arrivée de la ligne 18 du métro du
grand paris express va entraîner de
nombreux changements mais pas question
de vous les imposer l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est de vous donner la
parole pour un aménagement en douceur et
collaboratif j'ai trouvé très
intéressant qu'on nous implique dans la
construction du quartier des savoirs
parce que c'est un quartier qu'on va
utiliser qu'on aimerait pouvoir aller
voir régulièrement
donc je trouve ça bien de demander aux
gens qui habitent de voir ce qui manque
pour pouvoir étayer la demande qui
revient souvent c'est garder la verdure
voilà ce qui vraiment plein oui encore
toi c'est d'avoir un poumon vert d'avoir
de la verdure de pouvoir circuler en
vélo à pied ya vraiment cette volonté de
on est en vie mais à la fois on veut on
veut pouvoir vivre un peu comme à la
campagne soignant est infrastructures de
la ville
j'ai découvert ce quartier on en parle
depuis des années de la flèche thales et
que dire que de l'avoir découverte comme
ça ça va ça m'impressionnait est un
enjeu important pour retrouver un
recréer un quartier avec des équilibres
diversifier les commerces des services
accueillir des écoles peut-être à
marcher énormément de choses
intéressantes
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
démarche est de donner la parole aux
citoyens surtout et est donc aux
résidents pour voir un peu ce qu'ils
pensent du projet et surtout leurs
attentes leurs réflexions de projet doit
pas se résumer à regarder autour de ça
les petites chapelles il faut aussi
prévoir les impacts sur l'ensemble sur
l'agglomération
la gare est un pôle très attractif qui
va servir d'aimant et qui va donc
attirer toute la population de saclay de
l'yvette et de la haie de la lièvre
voire de ces braises mais aussi la
population du nord et aussi des gens de
montigny de lui encore tout ça qui se
partageront entre les deux graves
l'implication des habitants je trouve
que c'est une bonne idée ça permet aussi
de voir comment les gens vivent aux
alentours ce qui leur manque à ce qu'il
paraît intéressant comme le projet avec
une certaine diversité de des habitants
en 40 d'âge
cette hausse si ouvert aux gens des
communes voisines c'est aussi important
c'est une bonne idée de démocratie
participative avec les idées que j'ai
plus est m on aura peut-être une petite
satisfaction se disant que ça c'est une
map titid et elle a été retenue pour
maintenant l'amélioration et la création
de ce nouveau quartier appliqués les
usages et les acteurs locaux une
démarche impulsée par loupé à paris
saclay qui a donc fait appel à l'agencé
vraiment vraiment c'est activateur du
territoire nous propose une nouvelle
façon de penser de créer la ville il se
donne le droit de tester d'essayer et
surtout il se donne le droit de se
tromper un urbanisme transitoire que
nous présente joséphine combes c'est
l'une de leurs designers je suis et
joséphine kong
je suis designer chez vraiment vraiment
et s'agit d'une agence de design
d'intérêt général basés en france et en
belgique
on est une équipe pluridisciplinaire
c'est à dire que on a à la fois des
profils de designers d'architectes de
graphistes et d'urbanistes mais aussi
des profils de chercheurs et analystes
nos projets en fait porte sur les lieux
les parcours et les futurs de l'action
publique
le piano a missionné pour être
activateur de territoire dans les
contextes d'urbanisme transitoire
l'urbanisme de transitoire c'est une
façon un peu inédite de penser et de
fabriquer la ville en se donnant le
droit à l'erreur et ne s'est pas
conventionnel dans les veaux pratiques
d'aménagement de territoire
on va venir avaient des dispositifs et
des actions qui sont qui seront
temporaires aux réversible pour venir en
fait tester certains usages de nouveaux
usages
l'implication des acteurs locaux et des
usagers dans les différents processus
donc soit de conception de construction
et programmation c'est la clé de
réussite des actions qu'on va mener
parce qu'en fait en notre rôle en tant
qu à d'activateur c'est vraiment de
capitaliser sur des initiatives locales
existantes et de les aider à décoller
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
diagnostic dans laquelle nous arpentons
le territoire de la zac de moulon à la
zac de polytechnique à peu près et on va
à la rencontre des étudiants mais aussi
des familles qui sont fraîchement
installé mais aussi des salariés des
commerçants et des ouvriers et enfin
ceux de se saisir des enjeux et des
problématiques du terrain qui nous
permettront ensuite de proposer un
programme d'action pertinent quittera
mis en place à partir du mois de
septembre
en parallèle de ce programme d'action on
va aussi développer du mobilier qui
viendra soutenir ce programme est aussi
un concept de signalétique avec ce
projet on cherche à rassembler les
usagers du plateau qui vivent sur le
plateau qui vous pourrait
potentiellement venir de la vallée mais
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas de raison de
se croiser et ce afin de pouvoir
développer un sentiment d'appartenance
au territoire et aussi à l'appropriation
des espaces publics qui vont être encore
en chantier pendant plusieurs années
le design il trouve désormais sa place à
l'école normale supérieure paris saclay
avec la création d'un centre de
recherche ou quand les sciences se
confronte à la de nombreux doctorants se
sont lancés dans des projets qui sont
aujourd'hui exposées à le n s frédéric
parent directrice de l'école nationale
de création industrielle et pierre m
vice président recherche de la nes nous
dévoile ce laboratoire du design
[Musique]
le centre de recherche en design c'est
avant tout déjà une aventure fabuleuse
c'est la rencontre de deux univers
l'univers de la recherche scientifique
dans des domaines qu'on appelle les
sciences dures et l'univers du design de
la création du ce trial dollar qui on
appellerait parfois les sciences molles
qui viennent se rejoindre pour créer un
centre où effectivement à faire la
recherche en commun en particulier c'est
de permettre aussi à cette discipline du
design de faire de la recherche de
porter des doctorants qui vont faire des
thèses et de permettre effectivement
d'avoir des réflexions sur le monde
futur
de tous horizons et donc c'est
l'objectif de cette exposition ici
aujourd'hui que je vous présente c'est
de vous montrer les expéditions que
peuvent faire nos chercheurs aujourd'hui
sur ces territoires de la recherche
en rejoignant ses deux univers de la
recherche donc quoi de mieux que d'être
au sein de levens est ce magnifique
bâtiment ce qui est donc le bâtiment qui
accueille le centre de recherche en
design et quoi de mieux que ce lieu pour
vous exposer aujourd'hui tous ces
projets de doctorants le design à sa
place à l'école normale supérieure de
paris saclay aux côtés des sciences de
l'ingénieur saisi il ya une proximité
évidente entre le design la création
industrielle c'est celle intitulée de
deux l'ainsi et les cirques de
l'ingénieur qui font la singularité de
l'école normale supérieure de paris
saclay par rapport aux autres écoles
normales supérieures
l'intérêt principal de la création de ce
centre de recherche en design c'est la
recherche
on est ici sur le site de paris saclay
sur la première université française au
classement de shanghai s'est confirmée
en 2021
et donc c'était faire du design au coeur
de ce site de l'université paris saclay
et c'est là qu'on va pouvoir interagir
avec les sociologues avec les
informaticiens avec les sciences de
l'ingénieur au niveau de la recherche
[Musique]
est ce que le design existait au 2ème et
3ème siècle de l'époque gallo romaine un
passé dont les traces se retrouve sur le
site du campus urbain
regardez c'est une ville à une villa qui
date de l'époque gallo romaine les
vestiges ont été mises au jour
des archéologues fouillent toujours le
site et le public pourra le découvrir à
la demande marc dit les archéologues
nous dévoile ce lieu chargé d'histoire
on se trouve ici sur la place gibert
coudane donc à saclay sur le campus où
un site archéologique d'une maison qui a
été construite au deuxième siècle
troisième siècle à l'époque gallo
romaine a été réalisée donc et on voit
ici l'ensemble des vestiges qui
représente en fait la base de la maison
c'est à dire que en fait on ne voit pas
la partie supérieure ce que l'on voit
c'est en réalité la partie fondation le
plan est assez clair en fait on se
trouve ici sur la partie avant de la
maison et ensuite les pièces se trouvait
à l'arrière avec deux descentes de cave
qui sont encore extrêmement lisible
lorsque j'ai été consulté pour faire ce
chantier moi ce que j'ai défendu c'est
que enfin comment elle était convaincue
mais que d'une certaine manière il faut
remettre à la lumière ces vestiges pour
que
le public les habitants les étudiants
les enseignants etc comprennent la
présence d'un site qui est aussi relaté
l'histoire très très longue et en fait
tous très intéressants dans un endroit
où il ya de l'enseignement l'éducation
et oui justement cette question temporel
est vraiment présent on a travaillé donc
la consolidation des pierres les pierres
que l'on voit là en fait était aussi pas
mal des assemblées en fait il fallait
remettre dumortier entre les pierres ce
qu'on fait progressivement d'un mortier
qui est aussi un mortier de chaux donc
très naturel si vous voulez et qui en
respectant le format qui avait été bien
relevé par les archéologues qui eux
mêmes d'ailleurs sur le site on trouvait
aussi des poteries enfin différents
éléments qui sont un peu la trace de la
vie dans cette maison c'est un site qui
sera en fait pas accessibles sans
accompagnement
le public pourra rentrer soit sur
demande soit lors de manifestations
particulières des journées du patrimoine
ou autre jour et les archéologues en
fait continue toujours un peu a
travaillé 7 ce sont des bénévoles qui
continue à travailler toujours sur le
site
[Musique]
à vos agendas vous allez passer un bel
été des confiné beaucoup d'événements
prévus on commence avec le tedx à clessé
le 24 juin en partenariat avec le pea
paris saclay cette année c'est un
évènement 100% digitale 100% inspiration
sur le thème terre notre vaisseau vous
êtes plutôt espacées bien ne ratez pas
le space connect 21 c'est le 24 juin là
aussi cette convention dédiée au spatial
va rassembler des chercheurs des
étudiants des doctorants autour de start
up et institutions pour renforcer la
dynamique spatiale
on pensera très fort à thomas pesquet
retour sur terre d'élection le domaine
de corneville pour un bel été en famille
l'inauguration c'est le 10 juillet avec
beaucoup d'animations prévues le 20 août
des ateliers cirque est un spectacle
d'acrobaties nous vous en avions parlé
au mois d'avril laissez vous tenter par
le manège réalisé dans le cadre d'un
chantier d'insertion
alors vous pouvez en profiter depuis le
week-end du 12 juin
il est installé sur le parc de moulon
puis du 28 août au 19 septembre ce sera
sur le domaine de combelles ville et je
vous le rappelle l'accès est gratuit
vous aimez la petite reine ne ratez pas
la fête du vélo c'est le dimanche 4
juillet de 11 à 17 heures cette balade
libre ou guidée vous emmènera jusqu'à
versailles enfin des escapades
artistiques sont organisées par le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est du 26 juin au 11 juillet venez
accompagné musiciens danseurs comédiens
circassiens sur les chemins saint
quentinois et heavy mois voilà c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission je vous
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv je vous
souhaite un très bel été et à très
bientôt
[Musique]